cbs news medical contributor that's dr
david agus joins us now with more on
what this means for the u.s good morning
to you david agus good to see you
here's a question right off to off the
bat
the situation in the uk is that a heads
up do you think for things to come here
in this country
unfortunately yes
you know they have a higher vaccination
rate and a higher booster rate in the
united kingdom than we do here and
they're seeing omicron going from very
few cases to close to 40 percent of the
cases in the country literally in a
matter of days and so it is in every 50
state in 50 of the states in the united
states and it will start to spread at
this breakneck speed here also so i'm
certainly worried
we just heard boris johnson say a two
dose vaccine is no longer effective dr
dr fauci said basically the same thing
to us next week so does that mean we
need to really change what a vaccinate
what fully vaccinated means
no question they're bringing the
military out in the united kingdom to
help get boosters into arms and they're
already at 40 we're at 25 here in the
united states fully vaccinated right now
because the virus changed not because of
any other reason the virus changed fully
vaccinated is going to be those three
shots and i think it's critical that we
really push that across the country and
as much as possible the next week people
get their booster shot it works very
quickly within a week you're at a level
of immunity that will give you
protection
from symptomatic infection in most
people from omicron
all right dr aegis
vaccinations check get the booster shot
check now as we are introduced to these
new variants what can we do individually
to boost our own immune systems
so individually we have to just stop
spread of the virus and even if you are
vaccinated you could potentially spread
at a very low level so
avoid large gatherings wear masks when
you can in the uk they're recommending
work from home we're certainly not doing
that yet although we had over 2 100
deaths yesterday in the united states
and over 150 000
new cases so delta is spreading
dramatically as is omicron rising in the
united states so we may be changing our
behavior again in the near term
dr aegis thank you